[Music]
pikachu dulac from uh poor range
uh weak to crouch cancel
uh he has quite a few rough rough
matchups in this game pikachu still
isn't the greatest character most of the
tops here is good enough up close to
contest pikachu
whether or not there's like a billion
foxes and they're taking over and stuff
i'm gonna wreck them all with pikachu i
don't care
i don't care he's right near the edge oh
my god
[Applause]
[Music]
a pikachu has won a major smash summit
eight this is an impressive pikachu
pikachu i choose you
everybody knows what i'm supposed to be
right now everybody knows pikachu oh
yeah that's pikachu right there pikachu
pikachu no wonder so many people love
pikachu the character i think is the
best in the game is pikachu i would
definitely pick up pikachu pikachu's
busted and i've been saying this
is your champion glitch seven belonging
to the pikachu maid himself who is that
broken
[Applause]
look becoming the most popular fictional
character in the world isn't easy but
you know what is switching to geico 15
minutes could save you 15 or more on
your car insurance check out the link in
the description below for more
information now back to the story of
pikachu
you might have zero interest in fighting
games so these are all from different
games yes yes it spans the world of
nintendo do you know about all these
games yes so you have you've got no life
you've put in all of your eggs into this
basket maybe anime is not your thing
either
you might not even really know what a
pokemon is
ribbon
close enough it's venusaur
what but chances are you know pikachu oh
there it is
big fat pikachu v-max for a quarter of a
century now the sometimes pudgy adorable
yellow pokemon has been a part of
countless games movies and other forms
of entertainment pikachu has permeated
global culture in a way that can only be
compared to other universally
recognizable characters like mickey
mouse or hello kitty and its
electrifying rise is showing no signs of
slowing down pikachu first saw the light
of day in japan in 1996 that was part of
a cast of fantastical creatures that
were going to be featured in nintendo's
new game pocket monsters red and green
where these monsters battled one another
the anime series that followed shortly
after however was what really made
pokemon into a global phenomenon and was
also where many of us saw pikachu for
the first time that said pikachu wasn't
always meant to be the star of the show
in the original pokemon manga the
protagonist has a clefairy as their
partner pokemon and until a last-minute
script change ash was meant to get a
clefairy 2 instead of a pikachu in the
anime's first episode it's possible that
if that swap wasn't made pikachu
wouldn't have become the cultural
juggernaut that we know today every
pokemon looked different and had its own
set of abilities pikachu was stylized as
something of a cross between a squirrel
and a mouse in a bid to endear it to
children but underneath its cute cuddly
exterior lay a pretty fearsome power the
ability to zap anyone with a powerful
jolt of
electricity hi pikachu my name's ash
ketchum you and i are gonna be best
friends
this was pikachu in a nutshell most of
us have seen episodes of pokemon on tv
as kids but anime certainly wasn't
pikachu's final frontier it's also been
the staple of all the pokemon games and
more recently has had a role in a live
action movie in detective pikachu how
did you get in here i know
you can't understand me but put down the
stapler or i
will electrocute
you
being a star within your own franchise
is one thing but pikachu's reach
extended far far beyond the confines of
pokemon games and movies sure pikachu is
adorable but there's another side to it
that is the real key to its popularity
the original anime showed us not only a
surprisingly fierce fighter but also a
loyal companion to its trainer ash and
the combination of pikachu's cutesy
appearance formidable battle skills and
admirable devotion to its friends
created something larger than life
pikachu found its way into the hearts
and minds of both children and adults
everywhere
is it augmented reality
[Music]
pikachu became one of the faces of
nintendo and gaming in general it's been
featured on shows like the simpsons it
was japan's mascot for the fifa world
cup in 2014 they saw pikachu on the side
of planes trains and automobiles there
are even entire festivals devoted
exclusively to pikachu it's been named
as one of the world's most beloved
characters multiple times by multiple
sources throughout the years and on top
of all of that pikachu has had quite the
esports career as well
super smash bros was released in 1999
for the nintendo 64 and featured many
beloved nintendo characters including
mario fox donkey kong and of course
smash 64 never had the biggest
competitive scene but pikachu was
consistently ranked first in tearless
and had many advantages over every other
character in the game notably its
movement and attack speed warrior
running all the way over the up smash by
kiosk he completely whips but no real
punish very lucky to get out of that
scenario yeah i agree and i thought
wario was baiting him into that oh this
is a big combo from wario and then
hedgehog will do it you know a lot of
times pikachu can bait falcons into that
uh
up smash out of shield
they they want it they always want it
yeah i mean we want the grab usually oh
and another
short stock for kyoshiki great job by
wario in smash 64 pikachu basically has
no bad matchups and remains
unquestionably estier to this day he's
playing so fast right now oh he's
getting hit by a lot of stray aerials
and that's what's costing him so much
percent in so many stocks yeah uses that
egg to get back
rolls on
not a great move against brody
rolls on again that's it that's it
that's the game that's the set that's
the tournament but while smash 64 was
pikachu's playground its successor super
smash bros melee was where competitive
smash really began and it was an
entirely different story everything
pikachu had got nerfed in melee lower
damage kos were less reliable it was
slower everything was worse the contrast
between the top tier monster pikachu
used to be in 64 and the toned down
version they saw in melee was glaring
learning how to use pikachu despite all
the disadvantages it now had was simply
too much work but there were certainly
those who tried and even succeeded some
people are just really good at the game
and they don't exactly have a character
that clicks
the best they can just play a whole
bunch of characters and that's how it is
but i'm a character specialty
where something about pikachu just
clicks from me
that and he's just he's just fast he's
fun he zips around
and he's adorable changing high to the
platforms can really do a lot i'm
messing him up
potential stock gets the up tail spike
and suit attack
nice light shield not even trying to get
shield slam as the shields do get really
small like another stop pikachu
pika pika the pikachu champ is humongous
here oh ole man silent wolf
we've seen a lot of four stocks on this
stage before but 45 seconds solid won't
be down to his last stop is he gonna get
it before a minute passes
whoa let's see he's right near the edge
oh my
god destruction
[Applause]
that was emphatic that was
amazing
[Applause]
guided by acts pikachu's crowning
achievement came in 2019 when after
years of being considered nothing more
than a mid-tier pick at best it finally
became a major winner at smash summit 8.
oh my god
that was a weakness
thunder
[Music]
this is an impressive pikachu but not
even a major victory could sway people
into thinking that pikachu and melee was
built to win pikachu has one major axe
one summit that's why he's in the could
win major category
um so yeah but he's not a high tier
character he's not a high tier character
because he struggles pikachu struggles
versus icy speaking struggles versus
puff pikachu struggles versus um chic
uh horribly right like really really
uphill matchups and you can't be a high
tier character and have such
struggles matchups all right pikachu
continued to be a mid-tier pick in melee
and didn't fare much better in later
smash games while it came close to the
top of brawl and smash force tier lists
it was never the best character in the
game
oh my goodness oh man miss k is so on
point
he's saying doesn't have a whole lot of
answers for him and me too king says
it's not his character you know at the
end of the day it's still music can
still get the job done
that's game interesting we saw the
fallen character a lot of people will
follow up and upgrades after that i'm
curious to see what the f kill purpose
was behind he might not felt like he was
in rage to get the sweet spot up smash
so he felt like he wanted to guarantee
punish instead maybe oh my god
wow
it definitely had its moments in those
games but at the end of the day all
because you could really pull off in
rankings was a solid b pikachu rounds
out the beats here but pikachu still
isn't the greatest character he still
has lots of with character is that good
up close
and most of the tops here is good enough
up close to contest pikachu pikachu
wasn't really the character you picked
if you wanted results unless of course
your name was isam a player who pretty
much single-handedly carried pikachu
through both brawl and smash 4. it's
something to do with footstools and a
downthrow or something like that it's a
weird kind of gimmicky thing you can hit
it but it's just situated
and he looked at the
[Laughter]
whatever smash players opinions on
pikachu were though the rest of the
world was as into pokemon as ever with
the summer of 2016 being unofficially
dubbed the summer of pokemon go a
magical season that saw everyone and
their uncle out and about using their
smartphones to catch them all we did it
so okay here i almost like never mind i
have a shiny pikachu
what i dare a security guard to walk up
right now bro i'm juice so we have a
shiny
pikachu dude it's actually shiny pikachu
oh my god
a shiny pikachu never been done before
on the tubes i don't know if we'll have
to see esports took a couple of years to
catch up to the masses and it wasn't
until the 2018 release of smash bros
ultimate that saw pikachu make something
of a character renaissance pikachu
received some pretty notable buffs it
was faster did more damage it had better
kos and more this new and improved
pikachu may have taken some getting used
to but the long time pikachu mains were
right there to make sure everyone knew
pikachu was back here we go man
guaranteed damage
donkey kong just gonna have to hold that
l man
73 88 and it doesn't stop is that the
stock no stir oh trying to oh my
goodness it wasn't a zero to death but
it sure felt like it didn't go to the
back oh no let's go okay i like that i
like the other jump though oh no that
back here just scooping them in it is
doing me some work right now oh my god
he barely missed the lead he's putting
it up the wall so that what he's forced
to shield it and then it gives him a
freeway back on stage super smart oh
boom damn okay double f match not going
to register the backyard will though 124
can't get the fourth smash and
[Applause]
i can't believe i won
like i can because i'm godlike and
pikachu's busted and i've been saying
this
anyone any single person says uh ecm
pikachu can't be top three your top five
he has no results this is the result and
things have snowballed from there all of
a sudden pikachu was the talk of the
smash community for the first time since
its introduction in the original smash
bros pikachu was a character to be
feared and admired once again the best
character in the game is
pikachu busted pikachu busted pikachu
busted he's so good i think that he has
some of the best combos in the game his
characters are hard to play character
but
just toxic to play against toxic i would
definitely pick up pikachu if
uh my only goal in life was to weld an
ultimate the character i think is the
best in the game and i still always will
is pikachu pikachu is the best character
pikachu's recovery ridiculous amazing
you have upbeat you have side b you have
downbeats still on the ledge you get off
the ledge for free you have one of the
most spammable projectiles in the game
you have low percent combos and near
pseudo-infinite
loops you have kill conversions at any
point that you want more people need to
pick up pikachu it's not been two a
tearless city's tearless series that i'm
saying this and of course pikachu
continues to hold steady in other
mediums as well despite being around for
25 years and counting pikachu remains as
relevant today as it was when pokemon
was first released its popularity
managed to transcend time distance
cultural differences generational gaps
and many more factors that on their own
would have been enough to end the lesser
character i never said it's gonna look
amazing okay i just said it's gonna look
decent enough for five dollars like
everybody knows what i'm supposed to be
right now everybody knows pikachu oh
yeah that's pikachu right there what is
this one you probably recognize this one
i'm sure
it's my favorite it's a pikachu yeah
find a friend
oh that's so cute this is exactly what
it should end up looking like look at it
happy little creature no wonder so many
people love pikachu the secret to its
longevity is not immediately obvious but
as a cultural icon that has persevered
and thrived no matter the circumstances
pikachu tells us a little bit about
ourselves as people there's something
universally appealing about the idea of
hidden depth within everything around us
whether it's a cute yellow rat with
fearsome powers or finding touches of
magic in ordinary everyday places the
idea that a book can truly never be
judged by its cover
why pikachu
pikachu is cool
pikachu is great man
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]